you know I'm humbly I'll say that it has
actual tremendous abbr stantial impact
and how do how do I know that well
because my restaurant and now in with my
son Joseph and with Mario so on in
partnership we have more than 12
restaurants I have published just my
fifth book my television series in its
eight years and at the end of the day
there's 50 million viewers my books sell
in the four or five hundred thousand
copies so I I know I reach people out
there my show has been bought in
Australia New Zealand Asia satellite
Canada so I know that there is a want
for what the message that I'm giving and
I know that people are buying it and
listening so I humbled by this but I
feel it as a great responsibility oh my
proudest achievement test oh it's I
think I'm very proud of my family my
grandchildren my son and daughter that
have somehow even though they went into
their own education and field one in
Wall Street the other one in art history
and they reverted to the two continuing
my message I it's just the the
acceptance of what I do out there I
never ceases to amaze me oh my god is
calling me adventure oh my goodness yes
a visit to China and I'm talking about
several years ago China was still and to
the market of China one of the things
that I do when I go visit the different
culture is go to the markets but didi
the amazing of the diversity of needs
vegetables but the meats were
particularly every form and shape
whether it crawl whether they had ten
legs whether it had a long tail a short
tail every imaginable animal was hanging
somewhere in that market and every part
of that animal was dissected someplace
hanging ready to be eaten so it was just
mesmerized me that this culture yet the
oldest culture in earning it out there
there's something to say there about
respecting the food chain and maybe
eating everything that respecting when
you kill an animal whatever that might
be that you eat everything from it I
think it's something that the joy of
cooking certainly could be acquired at
any age I think because your palate does
not steer you wrong or does not lie to
you something looks good it really is
good and it's sort of it's beyond almost
up you can't block it personally just
goes directly so therefore i think that
exposure to that is absolutely necessary
as as parents or i think that in
cultivating that it begins at the as
early as you can at an early is early
age and that is having the aromas around
children as they grow up cooking around
them so that in the house this happens
so that the children get used to this
now they become friendly with the smell
of broccoli they become friendly with
this smell of cabbage and when they
begin to or the mother puts it in front
of them at the age of four five six it's
not a complete stranger so this familiar
resurrects familiarization with food
needs to happen immediately as one is
born
not this there's a lot of alienation
everything is packaged everything is
sealed you don't smell anything you buy
precooked food it's tough it's tough out
there I think just to relax and have
confidence in themselves I think that
everybody can cook on on a certain level
you don't have to be a master chef but I
think it's part of our survival mode the
nurturing nourishment mode so i would
just say relax be mentors you certainly
try to learn things from what is your
mother your grandmother whatever from
books from television and just attempt
it I think in the full in the field of
food and the big problem that we have is
the availability and the hunger that is
present in the world I don't think that
is necessary and the question that
follows of the answer that follows is
that will there be availability in time
to come so the environment and how we
take care of the environment and the
introduction of technology of industry
of whatever altering things are they all
for our benefits and ultimately are they
are we going to have enough food